and this is a Fox News Alert an
exclusive interview with America's top
diplomat Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson is on a South American tour
but Russia is very much on his mind
Tillerson talked with Fox News
correspondent rich Edson in Bogota
Colombia
good evening rich I understand the
secretary already sees evidence of
Russian meddling in the midterm
elections what can you tell us about
that
good evening shannond yes there and
throughout the world the Secretary of
State and I spoke an awful lot about
Russia a conversation that also led to
Russia's support of the Assad regime in
Syria to that he says that Russia really
needs to move to a different place on
this they can deny it all they want to
the support of the Assad regime as it
kills its own citizens but he says the
facts of the facts they need to go to
another spot then we discussed the
elections and Russia's capability to
interfere in the u.s. midterms there's a
lot of ways that the Russians can meddle
in the elections a lot of a lot of
different tools they can use I think
what we see and some of this is through
some of our own sharing with countries
that are allies of ours and partners of
ours and we are seeing certain behaviors
there are a number of important
elections in this hemisphere this year
leading up to the US team leading up as
well to the US the u.s. versus the u.s.
in 2018 so you know we're really I think
it's important we just continue to say
to rush you look if you think we don't
see what you're doing we do sit and you
need to stop if you don't you're going
to just continue to invite consequences
for yourself is the u.s. better prepared
this time around in 2016 well I don't
know that I don't know that I would say
we're better prepared because the
Russians will adapt as well if it is if
the point is if it's their intention to
interfere they're going to find ways to
do that and we can take steps we can
take
but this is something that once they
decide they're going to do it it's very
difficult to preempted the secretary
also says though he still wants to
continue to work with Russia to improve
that relationship Shannon written any
potential discussions being planned
between the Americans and the North
Koreans around the Olympics vice
president Mike Pence is at the Olympics
and the Secretary of State says the
Trump administration is not ruling out a
possible discussion president asked the
vice president to lead the u.s. official
delegation to the opening ceremony of
the Olympics in Seoul were there to
first support the successful Olympics by
the South Korean government we're also
their support all the United States
athletes that will be competing that we
expect to bring home a lot of medals and
whatever happens while the rice
president is there we'll just have to
see you know we'll wait and see and look
you're going to initiate this or does
the US and watch if someone has to make
the first move well look Vice Presidents
there and we'll just have to see what
happens the secretary though denies that
North Korea's participation in these
Olympic Games somehow counters his
international pressure campaign even
though it's giving North Korea and
international venue from rush hour in
Bogota Shannon back to you all right
Richardson thank you very much